so leute es ist soweit der start der
saturn 5 und zwar heute genau vor 50
jahren erhob sich das ungetüm um drei
astronauten zum mond zu bringen um dort
ihn dann zu betreten zum ersten mal in
der geschichte der menschheit jetzt
quasi live dabei hier ist krieg zum
science fiction abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er keins der täglich
faszinierendes seines videos los gehts
ja jetzt startet also die saturn 5 genau
vor 50 jahren und das war der endpunkt
eines langen wettlaufs auf dem weg zum
mond lange lag die sowjetunion vorne sie
hatten den ersten satelliten in den
weltraum gebracht sputnik sie hatten den
ersten astronauten oder bei ihnen
kosmonauten genannt in den weltraum
gebracht juri gagarin und jetzt also das
finale dieses großen wettrennens wird es
gelingen drei astronauten bzw 2 werden
auf den mond treten ja dieses abenteuer
bestehen zu lassen es ist wirklich ein
abenteuer gewesen denn nichts war
eigentlich sicher man hat zehn jahre
lang experimentiert mit zahlreichen
fehlschlägen viele erfahrungen musste
man sammeln zahlreiche astronauten
starben bei den versuchen drei sind auch
in einer apollo kapsel ums leben
gekommen einer kapsel wie sie heute vor
50 jahren zum mond abheben wird wenn
diese apollo kapsel war anders als ihre
vorgänger gar nicht so gut gebaut sie
hatte viele technische mängel über 1000
wurden nach einem schweren unfall in dem
ab drei astronauten in der katze
verbrannt sind wurden mehr als 1000
fehler festgestellt aber sie wurden alle
behoben und heute ist der moment wo
diese kapsel die jetzt wirklich extrem
ausgereift ist zum mond starten wird
noch 20 sekunden bis zum start der
countdown läuft dazu muss
wissen wenngleich 1 0 ertönt dann sind
vorher die gestalten damit sie bei mir
abhängen kann aber wann kann nein hier
erheben sich jetzt 2900 tonnen gewicht
in den weltraum eine unglaubliche
schubkraft hitze nach oben der ersten
sekunde hat sie etwa einen meter
zurückgelegt also startet extrem langsam
und wird dann immer schneller sie
beschleunigt auf mehrere 10.000
kilometer pro stunde
die erste stufe brennt und sie wird von
den 2500 50 tonnen treibstoff das
allermeiste in den ersten sekunden hier
verbringen nämlich genau 2000 tonnen
die sind nötig um überhaupt erst mal in
die erdumlaufbahn zu kommen
die rakete besteht aus drei stufen und
erst mit der letzten mit der dritten
stufe ist diese rakete oder dran das
raumschiff die apollo 11 überhaupt in
der lage die erdumlaufbahn zu verlassen
man sieht diese wahnsinnige power die
druckwellen die hier durch die wolken
gehen und betrieben und oben an der
spitze da sieht man noch ein kleines
dünnes türmchen
das ist der rettungswache eine
konstruktion die in not beifall bei
einer fehlfunktion oder von hand von
einem astronauten ausgelöst die apollo
11 kapsel von der saturn 5 trennen kann
in sichere entfernung bringen kann und
dann notlanden kann aber das ist bei
diesem staat nicht nötig und das war
auch die ganze zeit nicht nötig die
meisten unfälle sind leider am boden
passiert alles was im weltraum passiert
ist wurde dort gelöst und keiner kam
dort um aber am boden gab es eben die
ein oder andere katastrophe aber es
läuft alles glatt an diesem 16 juli 1969
und viele menschen saßen damals
millionen menschen vor den fernsehern um
das zu verfolgen
und ja alles läuft glatt die saturn 5
übrigens noch eine wichtige information
wurde entwickelt von wernher von braun
er war ja einer der entscheidenden köpfe
bei der entwicklung der v2 rakete einer
waffe des deutschen reiches mit dem
hitler großbritannien england bezwingen
wollte und die zahlreich in der
britischen hauptstadt eingeschlagen ist
und sie wurde dann die ganzen unterlagen
werden davon braun ergab sich quasi den
amerikanischen truppen und mit seinem
ganzen technik mit raketen mit plänen
und so weiter ist er dann in die usa mit
seinem kompletten team bereist und sie
haben dort dann nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg den raketenbau vorangetrieben
der nötig war unter anderem für die nasa
für den mondflug aber auch für
zahlreiche militärische projekte und ja
aber das ist glaube ich dann wirklich
größtes werk die saturn 5 die größte
rakete der welt mehr als 110 meter und
auch heute noch ist dieser rekord nicht
geschlagen worden parallel dazu hatten
die russen auf versucht eine riesige
rakete noch größer zu konstruieren die
n1 aber ihre beiden ersten start gingen
beide schief die rakete explodierte und
damit war dann das rennen im wettlauf
zum mond entschieden allerdings eine
gefahr gibt es noch und das werden wir
am samstag dann ab 21 uhr hier auf
klicks um die zahlreichen anderen
wissenschafts kanälen verfolgen
parallel zur apollo mission ist auch
eine sowjetische luna sonde auf dem weg
zum mond und wird parallel zu apollo den
mond umkreisen das heißt es gibt das
tatsächliche risiko dass diese beiden
raumschiffe zusammenstoßen und das ist
im moment die große furcht die die
amerikaner haben ja wie das ausgeht und
wie dann miteinander kommuniziert wurde
und es vielleicht zu seiner ersten
zusammenarbeit mit dem russen kam mit
den sowjetbürgern korrekter weise
da sehen wir am samstag bis dann
empfehle ich euch das video from
raumzeit block der zukunft dass alle
details zur saturn 5 rakete erklärt
dafür hier draufklicken und wenn er den
das leben nicht verpassen wollte am
samstag dann klickt ihr auf und
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran